with y'all's show uh with impractical
jokers you can't even talk anything
about it you guys have um
[Music]
joe is not going to be on the show
anymore yeah wow for now i guess right
yeah
um would did they ever did they try and
think about bringing somebody else in
well they asked us what we wanted to do
and we just thought about like a hundred
different permutations for and just
landed on the fact that we didn't want
to replace him yeah because that person
would be
already shot you know like it's hard to
replace him so we just were like
let's just uh right now we're bringing
in a guest each episode to just help out
with the like the punishment but it's
like people that we know that were
really psyched and interested to get on
uh you know so we've had like eric andre
method man uh jillian bell uh rob riggle
david cross
like all these like really cool guests
you know um and like we're booking you
know just and this we just uh we
finished season nine the last nine
episodes that we started before the
pandemic so those start aaron and i
don't know when this comes out but
those start airing june 16th okay and
then in two weeks we've been writing
season 10 and in two weeks we start
filming season 10. and we'll do uh for
the first time might we shorten the
episodes and we're going to do 18
because i want to kind of have six
months on six months off to do comedy
and stuff so we're doing 18 episodes
we've got 18 guests but then
check this out uh they're just in uh in
these in there is punishment and we do a
cold open with them and a couple of
interstitials so they like threaded
through the episode okay so they're like
anchored as the guests but in the middle
bits when we need four
we made it so that we can bring anybody
we want at all anyway so the idea at
first was like oh we could bring anyone
like from a comedian friend to our
family to literally like the thing was
we said the halal guy outside our office
yeah and we started doing that like i
brought my barber on you know we brought
like it just so because it's like just a
mixed bag you know yeah so yeah so we
did that and it's been fun you know it's
just a different energy and stuff you
know yeah so it's been good so we
started filming that in a couple weeks
wow yeah is it hard to stay motivated
with it as things get keep going that
much is it hard to like
not that you don't care about it but is
it what have you learned about that has
that been interesting
yeah i mean you know the motivation's
there you know because it's it's our
reputation and the show's been on so
long and you know i'm never gonna i'm
not gonna half-ass it you know yeah
but um
we said we would do the show until we
like stopped having fun but it's just so
much fun yeah you know and and you know
our crew is another 40 50 people that
you don't see well we put them on a lot
now we put our crew on but like so it's
not just us us having fun like
we've been with these people some of
them for 10 years so it's like this
family you know so we still have fun man
and we you know the the pandemic made us
have to rethink how we did everything so
we did a whole season in a pandemic when
we couldn't even go up to anybody so
that was fun because we have to we're
always trying to push and change and
evolve it and stuff like that so you
know so it's it's always a little
different each season like we don't just
go back and do the same bits we did like
when people describe the show they go
these you know these friends they put an
earpiece now to do and say what they're
told and if not you get punished that's
the most simple way to explain the show
it is yeah and it is like a third of the
show yeah and it was a lot of the show
when we first started but in the first
season or two but really if you watch
the show
that is just one element of it there's
so much we create so many scenarios and
games and situations and like that
aren't even beholden to doing and seeing
what you're told right right it's just
like that's the easiest way to that's
the elevator pitch right like so but
yeah we so we we you know we have fun
like like figuring all those things out
yeah yeah are you worried about not
having joe on there
you know i was because he's just you
know he's one of a kind he's one of a
kind
he's the funniest dude in the world and
and and then like but it's like you have
a recipe that's working and then you and
if you remove a main ingredient so i we
didn't know what to expect you know but
you know because the nature of the show
whereas like
we we
we are out there like we're we're always
switching who we're doing it with so
nothing felt foreign because i've been
out there just me and him i've been out
there with me i've been out there alone
just me
so in that respect it didn't feel like
completely foreign um and then
you know and then we were so focused on
getting the new formula to work and then
getting these energy from these people
that came on as guests
that like you know that kind of like
filled like a little bit of like what
would be and you know it took like it's
like when you get on stage you know we
got there you know we started to film
and we're like all right let's see how
this is going to be like i don't know if
it's going to be you know gloomy of
course we miss him you know yeah but
then you know you start laughing
and you're like oh [ __ ] i'm laughing i'm
laughing this is i had fun today right
and they're like all right all right
we're still laughing what's having fun
you know um
that's the barometer i think and that's
always been the barometer i think with
you guys as a group it seems like
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy
two
options watch one this one or this one